[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous lecture we were
discussing about the lamy strain
potential
and in the lecture prior to that we were
discussing about the
hemol's displacement potential now both
the hemos displacement potential
and the lamy strain potential represent
the
displacement vector u so let me write
this
so the hemhole's displacement potential
and the
lamb is spring potential
they both represent the
displacement vector u in terms
of first order derivatives
in terms
of first order derivatives
of of potentials
okay of course it was true
that in the case of the hemhos
displacement potential
the displacement vector was expressed
in terms of a scalar potential and
a vector potential whereas in the case
of the
lambda strain potential the displacement
vector
was represented in terms of a single
scalar potential but in both these cases
the commonality is that
that the derivatives were all
first order in nature now
gallerickin he came along and said
that it may be useful to represent
the displacement vector so that's what
is
how we are going to study today the
gallickin
potential
this is the topic of our study in this
lecture
so what he said was that it will be
useful
to express this displacement vector
not in terms of the first order
derivatives of potentials
rather in terms of the second order
derivatives
and you will see the consequence of this
shortly
uh another important
thing which galilean
mentioned was that
this representation can be done in terms
of a single vector potential so
immediately you can see
that there are certain important
differences both with the hemholes
and the laminar strain potential it was
true that in the hemel's displacement
potential
we had a vector potential which was our
capital
omega if you look back to the lecture
notes there
whereas in the case of the lambda strain
potential there was a single scalar
potential
now what gallatin said was somewhat of
the mixture between the two
okay so he's saying that the
displacement vector u
will be representable in terms of a
single vector potential so the form that
he gave
was like this
where this capital v vector
is the vector potential is the gallery
in vector potential
let me write that down this
v vector that is the gallerkin vector
potential
now looking at this form it is very easy
easy to wonder uh i mean how
how does one arrive at this i mean is
this some kind of black magic
certainly not okay and what i will do is
there is a clever way in which this
particular form can be arrived at
just from the from the initial
consideration
that all we want to do is to express
this displacement vector
in terms of second order derivatives of
a vector potential just from that
initial consideration
we can arrive at this particular form
but i'll not i'm not going to go down
that route in this lecture
rather what i will do is something
similar
to what i have been doing both in the
case of the hemos displacement potential
discussion
as well as the lamy strain potential
discussion and that is
to utilize this particular form
given that as it is given by galerkin
and to use it in the navier lamin
equation
okay so we go back to the navi lamin's
equation
which is lambda plus g
grad div of u
plus g
del square u plus rho b vector
as we had been doing in the previous
cases we keep the row b vector for now
and see the consequence of keeping it
all right
so what we are going to do next uh is to
is something that we simply cannot avoid
this complicated looking
expression for the u vector that we have
to substitute here
okay and please note that there is no
further simplification that is
immediately possible here
okay so we actually have to go through
the
algebra all right so let's do that
so what we have here is
uh so if we just substitute this for
this u first so
this one by twice g i'll take that out
of all these operators
that's lambda plus g by twice g
grad and now i'll i'll i'll actually
carry out this divergence
over this okay so i may be skipping a
little bit of
steps here and there
but i'm sure you'll be able to follow
along
so see this is the this is the
the first term that i have done here
this one
uh please note that when i am
operating this this or when i'm carrying
out this divergence
basically for this term this is the
divergence of the laplacian of the v
vector and what i have done is to take
the divergence inside this laplacian
in order to arrive at this term here
i have taken the divergence on this
gradient for which i am obtaining this
from which i am obtaining this
laplacian and is it turns out that this
one
and this one are i mean they are the
same kind of terms and we are going to
simplify this in the sum
in the subsequent step next for this g
laplacian of u we have to again
substitute this
uh this entire thing here now this one
by twice c
with this g so that will give us a half
so what we have here is 2 into 1 minus
nu
laplacian of the laplacian or v vector
that is the by harmonic operator
operating on the v vector minus
we have the grad of the laplacian
of the divergence of v
so let me just discuss what i did
you see this laplacian is operating on
this entire thing
the first term is taken care of by this
by a harmonic
for the second term this is the
basically the laplacian of the
gradient of the divergence of b and what
i have done is to take the laplacian
inside and put the gradient outside so
that's exactly what i have done here so
i've skipped this step here
okay and of course i have this
rho b vector term that is equal to 0
all right this entire thing is equal to
0.
okay now uh of course i can i can
simplify this a little bit
uh let me do that okay
uh
so this you note is basically
half lambda by g
plus 1
this is 2 minus twice nu minus 1
this terms this is this is this is
common
so what i obtain is basically
1 minus twice nu
and this gradient it can go inside
so what i obtain is basically gradient
of the laplacian
of the divergence of the v vector
and please note that this term is
kind of matching with this here
okay we'll see the consequence of that
next this entire first term is done for
this half and this 2 cancels so we don't
need
this we just have this 1 minus
nu y harmonic of v vector
and 1 by 2
gradient of the laplacian of the
divergence
of the v vector plus
ruby vector is equal to 0
now you see we have this lambda by g
plus 1 term let us see what is actually
that if we try to simplify it
okay so what we intend to do here is to
find an expression
for lambda by g plus 1.
now lambda is
e new divided by 1 plus nu
1 minus twice nu if you do not
remember this i would request you to go
back
and refer to the problem sheet on
material behavior
g is e by 2 into 1 plus nu so
and we have this plus 1 here so this 1
plus mu cancels with this one plus nu
this e cancels with this e
and what we are left with basically is
twice nu divided by
1 minus twice nu plus 1
which is nothing but 1 minus twice nu
and this should make you particularly
happy because you see
this lambda by g plus 1 that is
multiplied with
1 minus twice nu so that is basically
cancelling with this
so if you substitute it back here what
we are going to obtain
is half
grad of the laplacian of the divergence
of v
vector plus
1 minus nu
by harmonic of the v vector
minus half
gradient of the laplacian of the
divergence
of v vector plus rho b
vector is equal to 0 and of course very
nicely
this entire term cancels with this
entire term
so what we are left with is
with a little bit of
rewriting
transposing and dividing by 1 minus nu
we obtain this particular form
now again you consider what happens
uh so see as written
uh we can hope to
find some possible solutions of the v
vector
but things become uh really convenient
if we again consider the ruby vector to
be equal to zero
as we have been doing in the previous
two cases of the hemholes displacement
potential
as well as the lamy strain potential so
consider ruby vector to be equal to 0
then we end up with
del 4 v vector is equal to 0
and this again should make us
particularly happy
of course with the caviar that we are
working under this restriction of zero
body forces
but as far as the as the equation is
concerned uh this should make us
particularly happy
because this by equation form has been
studied so much
and the solutions to this are known in
very many different situations
for different geometries all right
so uh so what is the situation
so back in the hemos displacement
potential
we had ended up with similar kinds of
bi-harmonic equations
however in that case the the by harmonic
equations
were of two to two kinds so we had a
bi-harmonic equation
for the scalar potential if we just look
back at it
let me just scroll back and look at the
hemel's displacement potential framework
okay so this was uh what we had
discussed in the previous
lecture and prior to that
so this was the part where we were
discussing the the consequences of
considering the rho b vector to be equal
to 0 in the context of the hemhos
displacement potential
and we had obtained these two equations
the hash one and the hash h2 you see
that
that this was a bioharmonic equation
this was also a bi-harmonic equation
but uh but we had two of them those
things in the hemos displacement
potential
now coming back to the galactic the
galerkin
vector potential we are obtaining
a single by harmonic equation which
encompasses
our desired solution okay so this is an
important
difference from the hemholes
displacement potential
okay so you see the consequence of
working
or starting out with as galikin had
suggested
a single vector potential we are
obtaining a single
by harm well uh a single bioharmonic
equation
of a vector so this is basically
actually actually three equations
okay now
it is important to note uh that
if we are working in the rectangular
cartesian coordinate system
then
the different components of this v
vector
we will obtain decoupled equations or
decoupled by harmonic equations for
each of the uh the x y and z
components of the v vector but things
are not going to be so simple
meaning to say that suppose we
considered
a cylindrical coordinate system or a
spherical coordinate system
then the different components of the v
vector the by harmonic equations
involving those different components
they are not going to be decoupled
decoupled means if you are considering
so
so in the context of the rectangular
cartesian coordinate system
if you are considering the x component
the by harmonic equation involving the x
component will
only and only involve the x component
equation it will not have
any influence from the y and z
components similarly for the y and z
component senses
so so they are they are independent from
each other
but in the case of the cylindrical of
the spherical coordinate system
the suppose you consider the cylindrical
so if you if you
if you start out by writing the the or
if you write
intent to write the by harmonic equation
by taking the r component of this
you will see that there will be
influences from the other components
okay so that's what is meant by uh by
the absence of decoupling in the
cylindrical or the spherical coordinate
system
all right so there that is uh that is a
complication that we have to deal with
uh
another note another important to note
is that
this gallery in vector potential uh at
least
historically it was foreshadowed by
another kind of a potential
uh which was referred to as the love's
potential
so love a e h love was a famous
mechanician
uh so
he he he was he was also the author of a
very famous book
which was uh which is widely used
uh called the mathematical theory of
elasticity
and there was a time when people used to
jokingly say that in order to study
elasticity all you need is love
but that book has been i mean it's it's
still
uh referred to
but that has been succeeded by more
modern versions of elasticity books
anyway so that uh that famous
love uh he also uh gave
a potential uh a displacement potential
and uh his motivation was to study
various kinds of axisymmetric problems
all right and it turns out
that the love's potential is a special
case
of this gallery vector potential
now i mentioned this because
ultimately what we are building up to is
to be able
to develop a framework so that we'll be
able to
solve the kelvins problem
uh and if you if you refer to the
textbook
uh to our textbook um by martin sard
you will see that the solution to the
kelvins problem has been given
uh stemming from this gallerickin
potential and
and the and the way it has been given is
that you have been supplied with
uh with a particular form for this v
vector and you have been asked to
basically check out that it satisfies
the conditions for the kelvins problem
uh we will be taking a slightly
different route uh
and for that we'll develop another kind
of we'll discuss another kind of
displacement potential called the
babkkovic number
representation in the next lecture
but what i what i what i want to say is
that
the kelvins problem can indeed be solved
through this
kind of a representation or displacement
potential
uh and uh there are other problems also
which can be solved by this
category potential but a more modern
treatment
is is possible through the papkovitch
neighbor
representation which we'll discuss in
the next lecture
all right with that i i end this lecture
thank you very much